[Musique]
martine st clair on va revenir sur l'été
1984 avec la chanson il ya de l'amour
dans l'air c'est une reprise
oui pourquoi vous avez décidé de
reprendre sa chanson comment s'est fait
le déclic mais c'est pas ma décision à
l'époque mon équipe les dix que star me
téléphone une journée j'habite chez mon
père il me dit j'ai une chanson
extraordinaire elle a eu une vie en
france ça s'appelle ya de l'amour dans
la
[Musique]
ça parle un peu de cette jeune fille qui
qui voit l'amour tout autour d'elle mais
elle elle latin alors j'ai aujourd'hui
les parages dit les paroles je fais
comme je peux pas chanter je peux pas
chanter ce texte là c'est triste je dis
je dis non à l'agent et l'agent
téléphone à mon père monsieur nô
monsieur nô ça peut pas passer à côté ça
va changer sa vie c'est une grande
chance on parlait lui fait quelque chose
à mon père me parle de soins gros
meetings ou souples et vu qu avec les
sept autres à la maison des vite et donc
il m'a dit martin je pense que donne une
chance à la chanson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous rappelez de
l'enregistrement des lieux de la mode
alors comment ça s'est passé
surtout l'impact que ça eu cet été là
cet été-là de 84 comme vous le
mentionnez donc j'arrive ce qui est
impressionnant c'est que j'arrive dans
ce grand grand studio immense et puis je
ne me doutais pas qu'à la sortie de ce
studio que ma vie allait changer
je retourne chez moi et j'en ai des
frissons téléphone commence à sonner
telle radio accepter la chanson c'est
vrai on passe vite qu'elles sont vieux
de la fin alors dans les jours qui ont
suivi la chanson était pressé et envoyés
dans les radios et puis c'est devenu un
succès je serais presque momentanée
[Musique]
pourriez vous chanter juste leurs frais
et m'expliquer cascades magique dans
leurs frais ah oui ça l'est comme un ya
de l'amour dans le soin
et à de l'amour dans l'air
et moi je broie du noir
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour les gens cette chanson c'est comme
on m'en parle encore aujourd'hui c'est
comme un hymne
il faut voir le public quand je quand
j'attaque ce premier refrain les yeux
qui pétillent les gens qui sont heureux
eux déjà dvd des applaudissements chaque
homme brillant encore aujourd'hui et je
dois la chanter à chaque spectacle 40
ans après et aujourd'hui pour moi je
sais très bien qu'il ya de l'amour dans
l'air c'est à l'intérieur de toi tu sais
que de l'amour
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]